all right Jimmy ran devices go a little
they won't mix it up late linked to
hitting his first shot as he takes on
two members of the Bison defense weasel
kid who drives pretty good look at this
is that a good start get that out of
here his home area and why not show them
all what you can do his story they were
rich with a class act to increase your
bench at with daughters today is on nice
little high-low action pass from Bouldin
than Adam and here's the inbounds by
jones de williamson no stopping that the
lob just outmatched right over eating
the given up a lot of inches explicity
of their offense brand that's what I
think it's so easy to play Chris the
talent is extraordinary
[Applause]
what a janitor better stay ready with
extra rib I remember you in your heyday
could you bring it with this avenges
leave the chandeliers big fella
boy that is strong can you relate let's
go prove me wrong this is what they got
to do just and they want to get this
cake these kids and a week off these
first of all what a fantastic liar just
kids he wants to show the home folks
good elevate now watch the ball look at
the speed of this kids too quick timeout
Diane Williamson put it on the show for
his whole town here Wow fantastic
MTSU only one out of seven for the feel
of this half is what the sketch in his
arsenal little pump fake gets everybody
to bite and it get out away Berra with
the post up he's good inside two grand
show outside game yes what do you want
coach handle things in the corner here
for the Blue Devils
touch he'll be all ready
but this look at this with authority you
saw him slip a few times I would think
he'll be back next overtime it should be
the next TV timeout I agree me for this
guy you know the other point to of
leaving a myth having that that injury
and coming back for the a seat